stacy abrams rides again that's the
focus of tonight's angle
all right let's say you're lucky enough
to be driving a newer model let's say a
porsche suv with low mileage in pristine
condition
and some schmuck approaches you in a
parking lot walks up to you and asks if
you'd be willing to trade it
for his 2002 mitsubishi
it's dented on the driver's side and has
a muffler hanging off the back
you'd burst out laughing right
well that's what georgia voters response
should be upon hearing that stacy abrams
is once again running for governor
why on earth would voters there want to
give up economic policies that deliver
safety prosperity and job growth for the
misery of places like california and new
york
four years of governor abrams oh that
would mean four years of poisonous
racial recriminations four years of high
taxes on businesses and families
four years of mask and vaccine mandates
four years of smash and grabs increasing
violent crime
and four years of anti-american
propaganda in georgia's schools
in other words
four years of economic and cultural
decline
now we've seen how this movie ends in
blue states across america
what we told you at the start of the
pandemic when blue states refused to
open
was that the red states that reopened
early
would leave them all behind
and that's precisely what has happened
check out today's headline in california
sacramento b
the economy is booming so why is
california's unemployment rate so high
uh i don't know
maybe devastating stay at home orders
that got millions used to being at home
and getting paid for it
generous unemployment benefits and
outrageous taxes
have sent businesses like tesla fleeing
the state to friendlier places like
nevada and texas
california has only clawed back about
two-thirds of the 2.7 million jobs they
lost
since the pandemic began
in fact they don't expect a full
recovery
until the end of 2023 and i think that's
generous
but of course
just as they protect gavin newsom from
culpability the press would protect
abrams if she ever won state office
again
she'd never be held accountable no
matter how bad things got
now compare california's train wreck to
the economic miracle that's been
unfolding in the peach state under
republican governor brian kemp
georgia's unemployment rate dropped to
3.1 percent in october the lowest rate
since the feds began keeping records
back in 1976.
now remember kemp was smart enough to
end the lockdown's earliest earliest of
all states even though he was criticized
criticized for it by everyone from
president trump to pelosi and even
abrams herself there's nothing about
this that makes sense these businesses
that are reopening are going to force
frontline workers back to the work
without having been tested without
having access to a health care system to
help them if they are in need by trying
to push a false opening of the economy
we risk putting more lives in danger
talk about a big whoops
now georgia's job growth
off the charts since may of 2021 jobs
are up by a hundred and seventeen
thousand four hundred and october marks
only the fifth time since 1990
that month over month job growth was
over 20 000.
so abrams can't spin away hard facts
it's red states like georgia that are
driving almost all of the nation's job
growth now from the wall street journal
the pandemic heightened the economic
policy differences between the two
political parties the states have
provided a market test and gop policies
won
the white house has taken credit for the
pandemic policy results in florida and
georgia
not in new york or
california
stacy abrams cannot leave georgia
because she's incapable of telling the
truth even when she's been caught on
tape
now last night she claimed that she
never contested the election back in
2018. on the night on the 16th of
november when i acknowledged that i
would not become the governor that he
had won the election
i did not challenge the outcome of the
election unlike some recent folks did
a flat out lie session means to
acknowledge an action is right true or
proper i cannot conceive why haven't you
conceded because concession means to say
that the process was fair do you still
maintain the 2018 election was stolen
that was stolen from the voters of
georgia
not only did she refuse to concede the
election
she suggested to the new york times in
april 2019 that she got more votes than
count
what we call attention to are the 1.4
million plus who are purged in the 53
000 who weren't processed and the
thousands were given provisional ballots
and you can't count on the fact that
abrams will use race to nix any law that
makes election results less prone to
fraud like the election integrity law
that kemp signed earlier this year
it's racist it is a redux of jim crow
in a suit and tie we know that the only
thing that precipitated these changes
it's not that there was a question of
security and the only
connection that we can find is that more
people of color voted
to always race
the woman is untalented unprincipled and
incapable of discussing almost any
subject intelligently
if she's not grandstanding on race she's
fear-mongering about january 6th
what we saw happen across the states
this year is going to be redoubled
starting in january when new state
legislatures come back when they feel
the fervor of the insurrection filling
their veins again they're going to
continue to pass voter suppression
legislation
filling their veins really how dramatic
abrams like biden falls back on personal
anecdotes that don't connect to today's
georgia
i was from a low-income community i'd
grown up in mississippi we'd moved from
mississippi to georgia we were poor but
they didn't think we were poor enough so
they were going for permanent poverty
well the truth is african americans
today in georgia are thriving under
republican leadership
atlanta is tied with washington d.c and
forbes recent study of where african
americans are doing best economically
so what exactly is stacy abrams done to
help georgia since she lost in 2018
well she led the crusade to push the
major league baseball all-star game out
of atlanta
uh what did that do well it cost the
majority black city of atlanta up to 70
million dollars in lost business
georgia this isn't even a close call why
on earth would you want to sink into the
decline and decay that we're saying in
blue states across america
georgians don't need abrams to ride to
the rescue
they need her to ride into the sunset
and for good
and that's the angle